[موسيقى]
العمده وعايزين عمده تل شابوره
هو انتم عاملين قوانين خاصه
ان انا جاي اطبق القانون حد ليه شق
[موسيقى]
ق في حاجه مرحبا من ملاحظه توجه النجمات
المهن مغايره عن الشكل التقليدي السائد
للمراه في السينما ودراما في عده مسلسلات
في هذا العام ابرزها ظهور روبي او عمده في
مسلسل حضره العمده بعد ما ظلت التلفزيون
او مخلص لنموذج المراه التقليدي طوال
عشرات سنوات مضت وهو امر يبدو ان
المشاهدين احبوا حيث تاتي اصداء العمل
جيده بشكل ملفت انا مسلسل حضره العمده
اللي عجبني فيه ان هو بينشر
تمكين المراه اولا بنش قضيه الختان
جواز القاصرات الاجره غير شرعيه فهو
بيناقش قضيه مجتمعيه مهمه جدا في اي مسلسل
في اي عمل اكيد يعني لازم توصل له حاجه في
الاخر توعيه يعني فالمسلسل
عجبني للنقط بصراحه طبعا من خلال الشخصيه
انا بحاول اساعد العمده مع اني برضو عندي
حته زي اي راجل عنده فكره تشكك في الاول
في المراه انها هتقدر
يعني تحتل هذه المكان القياديه وانها تمشي
خصوصا في مجتمع الشنب هو مجتمع الذكوري
الريفي البسيط
ها كما انه يجمع اجيال مختلفه حيث يشهد
حضره العمده منافسه في التمثيل من
الفنانين المشاركين فيه في قريه التل
شبوره اللي ترمس في العمل الى مصر معبرا
عن بعض المشكلات الاجتماعيه اللي اثارت
الجدل كزوجه مثلا لما اريت الدور طبعا
عجبني يعني وحسيت فيه بحاجه جديده اول مره
اعملها هو شخصيه مسعود المجبراتي اللي
بيبيع
حاجات كثيره قوي عشان اسفر ابنه طبعا شفته
في الحلقات اللي اتعرضت ان ابنه توفى في
البحر ليه الهجره الغير شرعيه فطبعا هي
ماساه طبعا يعني
وعزا لجميع الشباب اللي موجودين دلوقتي ان
هم يشوفوا انتوا بتبيعوا كل حاجه هنا عشان
تشتروا الموت المسلسل فعلا في فكره ذكيه
جدا فكره ان هو بيلخص يكاد يكون مصري كلها
في القريه اللي بتدور فيها الاحداث اللي
هي تل شبوره يعني من خلال كده بنقدر نشوف
بقى كل الطوائف المجتمع وبنشوف كل الناس
وبنشوف
وبنشوف رد الفعل الاحداث حصلت في المجتمع
المصري فتره فاتت دي كلها
[موسيقى]
لستوني كتير وفجاه عزتني انت واخواتك يوم
جوزي وكمان تقول لي عايزينك عمده بلدنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات